you put 815 people in an auditorium and
you speak in front of them you know
you'd be like holy crap I made it if I
sit and told you right now that somebody
had a thousand followers you'd say okay
that's cool but you know that's on the
lower side of the spectrum you've got
people who've got hundreds of millions
of followers of course to anybody who
wants to make a living doing it
absolutely for a lot of people listening
right now like I'm [__] kill for a
thousand followers exactly when you
start to look at whether it's
subscription or you start to look at
backers of your project whatever that
may be that's a lot of people I love you
for that because do you understand what
815 people that want to see what you
have to say looks like physically but in
this world you're like I'm an impostor
Center my son I'm like you don't suck